I can't believe you're doing this right
now Luke Wilson well which Luke is this
how do you know Drew Barrymore
oh
um
will the real Luke Wilson please stand
up I had no idea
what he was about to say I love to be
funny I want to push the envelope Kate
Hudson stops by the Drew Barrymore show
where the a-listers bond over their
dating history I dated Luke I did it
Owen of course that's Brothers Luke and
Owen Wilson I feel like we should
we should do it on the show
[Laughter]
yeah what could go wrong I'm gonna call
Luke I haven't called him and I don't
know
what if it was some random
Luke
Wilson
no
no wait is this Lily Luke
yes oh this is a different different guy
are you looking for the actor yes
okay it's not the loop they wanted but
Drew and Kate needed some answers how do
you know Drew Barrymore
[Applause]
I'm sorry we're Craig calling people
right now
[Applause]
hi it's true it's so nice to hear from
you I'm
so sorry
yup seems Drew met him on the set of her
classic rom-com I
had so to recap the search for Luke
Wilson was a bust but Drew's got plenty
of closure with axes thanks to her talk
show great to see you and was so happy
when you invited me on the show I think
that just felt so right for us to
reconnect there's something that feels
very comfortable about this forum to us
we're just reuniting on National
Television yeah this is wild speaking of
Drew's love life Kate also takes a stab
at playing Cupid was good to hear from
you it's so wonderful to hear from you
too are you single
this is Kate Hudson who you're talking
to but I just have to say
for someone who's being called called
you your behavior is absolutely stellar
and wonderful and you're a very cool
person I love talking about dating
everybody's looking for love well Drew's
got a circle back if this turned into a
meet cute that was so much fun oh my God
he sounded like he had a great voice hot
Voice by the way when he you asked him
where he knew me from I had no idea what
he was about to say but in the meantime
Drew's manifesting her dream guest in
the new year hello you've got to come on
the show
[Music]